hey let me tell you this we actually got
into an argument not too long ago and
this one was the funniest harder than
ever and I told this to a lot of
different homegirls and they didn't
understand this your homegirls are
different from my homegirls
okay well we'll tell this to it we'll
ask the audience then also the audience
is your fan so acknowledge I can't
always disagree with me so it's okay so
she got mad at me because of the way
that I respond to her when she asks a
favor so when she asks something right
so for example she'll be like throw away
the trash I go sure she gets upset Aloha
she'll be like do this with Matt go yep
I don't say throw away the trash I ask
you very nicely well of course it
doesn't matter either way I say yes and
then what do I do
do I do it or do I not do we converse
okay I think that's the problem is
because you're not telling my point of
view okay okay okay your point of view
first is a request when there is a
request that I need someone else to do I
think about how they want to hear for me
because I know David doesn't like to be
command demand exactly because it's a
favor when you ask for favors you have
to ask nicely
exactly so when I say when I want him to
take that take out the trash I don't say
hey take out the trash no you don't
that's never said that you just can't
rewind this you'll hear it you said
that's that's what you said I said that
how you demanded out of me no you said
take out the trash no I'm not saying
that's a problem though even if you said
it like that it's not that's been a
problem it is a problem because you
don't like to be demanded I should make
sure that I say in a way where you could
hear me but hey if you said this hey can
you take out the trash fine
mm-hmm but if you said like this take
out the trash mm-hmm that's different
mm-hmm right hey you don't have to go
hey okay first of all I don't do that to
you that's you exactly that's just to
show how nice I ask you think she asked
us you should see how nice she's going
when I ask when I ask I'm like this
hello whoa can you please take out this
dinky twist piece because it she mails
by the way I always take out the trash
ain't never take out the trash once
their life she don't know where the
garbage can is
but now you want to close the time where
you didn't know where the dishwasher
soap was so this wraps up the podcast
thank you guys for coming out to this
but you know was she saying that she
asked really nicely which I understand
because when you ask a favor from
somebody especially in this household
you should ask nicely when I respond she
doesn't she's not happy with my response
my response is got it and then I do it
what's the problem your job on yep got
it
I asked him three seconds later sure
what's that problem it still doesn't
make sense so you know what the three
seconds later I'll bring it the specific
example she's talking about right now
specific so there's this beautiful just
desk that I had shoutouts to my old desk
I miss you very much we had great times
together the way that you were shaped it
wasn't it wasn't like a normal square
desk it was like some rock cut wood and
I liked the fact that you were super
wrong with it
I missed you very much I wrote a lot of
sketches with you hold on a second let
me just I know exactly where it is right
now yeah shout out to the to the couple
that bought it from me I hope you guys
take care of Esmeralda very well she hey
stop laughing this is serious thank you
for taking camera very well she was so
she was important man her curves her
shapes
she she had two women in the house
Esmerelda's a man actually the way the
shape of his legs and penis was
fantastic I'm like anyways so she was
asking me to move things out the way
because these dudes were gonna come over
and they were going to pick up the desk
right and she goes hey can you move the
toosh so we have these two shortest shoe
storage things up on the stairs and I
have to move them out the way first so
they could bring out the desk so she
goes can you do that I pause for three
seconds I go got it and she's not sure
sure whatever
I hope sure what the reason why she was
upset was because that three-second
pause do you know what I was doing in
that three seconds
I was thinking thinking oh there's a
buffering now Olson you talk like
and first of all don't ever call me mm
okay second of all second of all I was
thinking about where I should place the
shoe thing to get it out the way to
require less work because my foot was
busted so I wasn't thinking about oh she
asked me this favor
I wasn't thinking like oh she's being
annoying I was thinking okay how am I
gonna do this and I said sure and what
did I do
did I complain about it it's funny I
want to yes or no right now please no no
you didn't do that did I Do's it my dear
did I did I do sit with a broken foot
did I do sit really well
tell me right now you did fine thank you
it's funny how you've brought up the
example of the trash but then you ended
up with the specific example that you
recall what treasure is all nothing to
do with the trash example I'm only
talking about the trash example what
about the trash example I asked you
honey can you take out the trash please
and then you had pauses that's why to us
and be like sure and it's not three
seconds though the tracks thing was
never three seconds those are lies lies
pure lies it's like this can you take
out the trash I go got it one second
boom in your face it has never been
three seconds are you lying right now
before God this is why it's so hard to
have a conversation with this man where
you talk - I need a workout daily - let
the stress out I'm talking to a wall
that has a mouth but no ears I do I
listen I listen to everything that you
say but I'd be breaking it down dude
yeah cuz you're so stubborn